how many times chris do i introduce
somebody who's saying i love this guy
i did that with weber i know i do that a
lot a lot
and certainly if people are new to the
show because we're on a new platform on
peacock
we have a lot of love exactly we do
uh i've known him for a very long time
way back to his pittsburgh steelers days
and uh formerly of the denver broncos
now formerly of the
defending uh nfc champion san francisco
49ers
and a member of the new orleans saints
and what an addition this was
uh in the non-playing season in the nfl
lots to talk about with emmanuel sanders
here on the rich eisen show wide
receiver the saints how are you sir
i'm good are you rich better for talking
to you better for talking to you oh my
god oh my god what's going on in that
great brain of yours sir
what are you thinking these days uh with
what's going on in the world i'm
thinking
i'm thinking the win win win and
coronavirus stay away
and uh you know uh social
uh social justice so just just trying to
create change
somehow some way just trying to think of
ways in which you know
we can have an impact allow people to
understand
you know sometimes my brain would
explode and just try to think about ways
because you know it seems like the more
and more i think it just seems like
there's
there's no out to it because at the end
of the day you know
people will say this say that and then
you give it time
you know the next big issue comes along
and they forget all about it then it
just keeps repeating itself so
it's it's it's exhausting for sure yeah
i mean that's a one way to put it
exhausting
i mean um you're you're active on social
media when when you can be
at e sanders underscore 10. um
i imagine you saw the the um the
shooting
in the state of wisconsin of jacob blake
um what'd you think of when you saw that
video in the in the palm of your hand
sir
oh i was disgusted it was disgusting and
uh
it's crazy because you know here i am
you know
you know i'm an african-american i don't
really i don't do any bad
still you know i've been racially
profiled um
just driving just driving my car officer
i was out here in new orleans the
officer pulled me over and said i was
doing 75 miles an hour and i ran a red
light when i know i didn't run a red
light
and uh he told me to get out my car i
got out my car and
you know we we talked and he kind of he
let me go but
uh then i'm i'm leaving work and i'm
driving home
down the same road and this is probably
about five hours later i see down the
same road i'm driving and i look to the
left and
i see an african-american being outside
of his car
and a cop talking to him and then i
drive probably less than a mile down the
road and i see another african-american
outside of his car talking to a cop and
i'm just like wow like
they're racially profiling down this
road right now because it happened to me
this morning and
it's not a coincidence that it's it's
two of them outside of the car
just how i was and i just said i was
doing 75 and i know i wasn't doing 75
and so
i was you know it kind of hurt my
feelings you know and and
it just goes to show you know uh you
know it's plenty of situation you you
take
three or four cops there and you're
telling me they just can't you know
tackle this guy and get him to the
ground you gotta shoot this guy seven
times in the back in order to make a
point and
why shoot a guy seven times with his
back turn that's just unbelievable and
so
for me you know i think the draining
part is everybody's talking about you
know
good cops bad cops but i just think that
you know there has to be some
type of laws that's changed in terms of
you know
i was telling one of my my boys over
there i said it takes
almost seven years to be a doctor it
takes almost you know five
six years to be a lawyer it takes all
these years to be this but it takes 18
months to be a
officer and carry a gun and carry out
duties like how is that possible i think
it should be on the same level
you know and so i i just feel like
something has to change and i
you know it's crazy because i know a lot
of people
understand it's like oh it's just oh it
didn't happen to you or
or or why do you care like you know
people these
you know caucasians are getting killed
and hispanics are getting killed and
it's just like
we all understand the bigger picture of
all this and it's like
when is it really going to change you
know when is it going to change and
it's scary to say like i don't know how
it's going to change
you know until um there are laws made
and it has to be consequences to it and
i think that's the most exhausting part
about it
emmanuel sanders the new orleans saints
joining me here on the rich eisen show
uh you guys practiced today uh but uh
you you had a special uh marking on your
helmet is that a fact
today yeah what was that yeah what was
it
so we so we so we had uh jacob's name on
our helmet
yeah i think it was it was uh it was
cool
um you know it was cool to see
but in my head you know and a lot of my
teammates i feel like we got to do more
uh to try to bring awareness to it and
we're going to all get together
and i know drew's going to be a part of
it and you know a couple of guys you're
all going to be a part of
whether it's me with the new orleans
police department and
trying to break down some type of unity
or or or or just try to do more to bring
more awareness to it but
you know and in my eyes and you can hear
it in my voice and i don't
i don't like to be a pessimist but uh
like i said it's this dream
because it's just like you know this
isn't the first time that we've had to
do this
we've been taking we've taken a knee you
know we've
we've done it all you know we we brought
we brought this to like so many times
over and over and over and over and over
and it's like when is it really gonna
stop you know like
like like it's not gonna stop unless
like i said it has to be a law it has to
be some consequence there has to be some
type of adjustments to bringing light to
it
it just seems like it's going in one ear
and out the other
i i i totally hear you emmanuel
um and you know yesterday
was in fact four years to the day
that kaepernick took a knee for the
first time um and
and and i i would say um
there has been some change of the way
that's been viewed
by the country as a whole over the last
four years but then again
again i'm a white 51 year old man you've
got two
you got two small kids at home right and
yeah i don't have to have the same
conversation with my
slightly older kids than you're going to
end up having uh
with princeton and maybe zoey right and
so
it's a dif we come from different um
obviously color skin but i feel the same
way you do
and and and you've been having i mean
you want to talk about deep
conversations on this subject
since you've even gotten to new orleans
you mentioned drew brees
i mean when you say drew's going to be
part of it walk me through the
conversations that the team's had
in general on this subject over the last
several months and
where things stand right now oh you know
we got drew we got about them so we had
to bring
those two guys together uh you know in
the zoom
zoom meeting just just to talk about you
know you know
uh what happened in in minnesota and
with george lord and uh you know drew
got on and
you know he apologized because you know
at the end of the day like
what he what he said he didn't really
understand
what was really going on at the time you
know and he was just speaking from his
perspective and
you know drew got on and he was he was
honest and he showed his true colors and
he cried
in in front of the team you know and
just just letting us know like you know
he apologizes and that
and that if anybody ever thought that he
wasn't on our side and
they have him wrong as a human being
because he he's
not like that and just being around him
i definitely understand you know
i run through a brick wall for that guy
man he's such a good dude man
i love how he comes to work every day so
those were the common
conversations and it's just it just
blows my mind that
you know those are the conversations
that we were had with her that we were
having
three months ago four months ago about a
guy that
had an officer on his neck and you would
think that you know once the world saw
that
you know these officers would slow down
and then three months later you got an
officer shooting another guy
in the back with his three kids in the
car and shooting the guy seven times in
the back because we were trying to kill
his dude over
over over what you know like when the
situation could have been resolved way
better than that and these are
trained officers you know and so uh
you know i can't i can't i can't say it
enough it's exhausting
it's really exhausting it blows my mind
that i know because i know that
could easily be me yeah that could
easily be one of my cousins that could
easily be one of my family members and
it's scary
it's it's extremely scary because like i
said
i just got pulled over out here in new
orleans with a cop just
i know he was racially profiling me and
so for me
like it takes you off to notice the
reason why you're really pulling me over
because i'm a black man and i knows it
and you know that i know this too but
you just make up something and i noticed
you i know that this is the only reason
why
and so some sometimes people fail to
realize it's like
i know you only pulling me over because
this
because i'm an african-american but you
want me to remain calm but you
it's if you're racially profiling me and
so you want me to remain calm when i
know that i haven't done anything wrong
you only pull me over because of the
color of my skin
you know like like that that that the
film will take
anybody off and so you just want it you
want to talk about somebody getting
picked up these officers are trying to
stay calm and they get picked up over
somebody saying something bad
you know and and you're trained to
become through every situation
you're trained to be able to handle
these these situations you know
so like i said it's it's exhausting to
talk about because it's it's very
repetitive
and uh you know i just hope change comes
emanuel sanders the saints here on the
rich eisen show um
this is a total hypothetical um because
as we all know there are no preseason
games this year because of
by the way you mentioned covert a while
ago
to start the conversation we haven't
even hit that subject matter but
um if if uh if there were preseason
games do you think
nfl players would have done what the nba
players did
last night uh i don't know
i don't know uh you know for me you know
i sit back and i look at the situation
and say okay
yeah you postpone the game but you know
what it what is the what is the end goal
to it right
what is the end goal to it what is it
what is it truly shown you know
and so i don't know i don't know it's
just it's a sticky situation with me i
support what they're doing
oh you know i i you know but to me
what's the what's the bigger picture of
and i don't see the bigger picture
and so to cancel a preseason game
which guys have an opportunity to
showcase their talent to play
you know to make a team and make a
living for their family i don't know
you know but you know i understand it's
bigger issues and i'm trying to find a
bigger picture too but like i said
that's the most exhausting part because
it's like yeah
we sit out one game but then the next
game we play so what
what what what is the true meaning of
what is it really changing
and so for me i i i'm trying to find a
bigger picture and
i i just can't see it and the only way i
can see it is through
through uh the government and through
uh you know hopefully a president making
laws trying to do something to to bring
some kind of change
all right and in the few minutes i have
left the first three words you said were
win-win-win when i asked you what was on
your mind here uh when i heard you got
signed there we we had you on the show
right then right then and there it just
sounds like you're a perfect
fit and that you got the right qb and
your right coach
and the right situation and michael
thomas also uh on the field i mean it
just seems like a total chef's kiss
what's it been like for you so far and
what you think you've got in front of
you
for 20 years it's been fun i know the
opportunity i got ahead
and i'm blessed to be able to have this
opportunity in year 11 to be in the
situation i am
i tell you what it's not a day that goes
by that i wake up in the morning i tell
myself to capitalize on this opportunity
and so that's what i'm trying to do
you know i've been putting in overtime
i'm i feel like a rookie
you know i feel like a rookie in terms
of staying after practice for one
withdrew
and just trying to try to get that timer
down because i know if i get open and i
win that ball is going to be on the
money and it's been under money since
day one and
you know play opposite of mike thomas
and knowing that you know
being on the number two cornerback and
sometimes they're gonna be
double-teaming him and my job is to take
the pressure off him
oh boy just just just make it make it
hard on the defense it's gonna be fun
and camara there too and breeze knowing
exactly where to put it
pre-snap post snap oh my work and you
know i mean you've been around some
young receivers who are extremely
talented
uh very fast young receivers who are
extremely talented and also
physical receivers where does michael
thomas rank
for you i'll tell you what it's one it's
one eight all the way across the board
with him demaryius and
uh antonio i was with all those guys
when they were at the top of their game
and so
um you know if i if if you take those
three and you make the perfect receiver
you know just just demaryius yards have
to catch michael thomas with his hand
demary saying michael from a physical
standpoint is just antonio brown just
his grit and
uh just since running after the catch
you will make the perfect receiver
and there will be no receiver better
than them so to play with them guys man
uh
it's been an honor and really a blessing
just to see it
you know just to see the greatness
within all of them in their prime
so uh you know i'm excited to play
alongside him as well
and and last one for you do you think we
get a full season in here i know that
testing hopefully is going to be
improved
you know the only the only thing that
scares me about the season and
it's going to be the bye week when
players have that time often with
families coming
coming in town fresh off a plane to go
to a game that's the only thing that
really
really truly scares me and so if we can
if we can control that i feel like we
could possibly uh finish the season but
like i said i just feel like you know if
one person gets in and spreads like the
red shield could be bad
yeah bye week bubble or something like
that i don't know yeah we're gonna have
to do something but
yeah so far so good right so i'm
optimistic i'm knocking on
lucite my desk right here emanuel uh
you're the best
really appreciate you joining um it's
great to catch up with your best to your
family and best to everybody there in
new orleans
and certainly you got it that's emanuel
sanders right here on the rich eisen
show